dans cette scène tout à fait moraliste
vous dit de tout temps chaque chose a eu
son anti donc deux exemples vous
rappelle
voilà muet cette année c'est un outil
parlement manhattan à anna t71 antimoine
voilà incroyable qu'un croyant c'est un
antiseptique voilà et les arabes du
caire sont entichés vite et les sémites
sont antiquaires pas de me demander
comment je viens avec notre fantastique
vous expliquer la dégradation des
valeurs morales parce qu'en fait le
comics et une dégradation de valeur au
tout le monde le sait ça c'est
fantastique d'ailleurs quand on sait qu
il ya une histoire qui est quand même il
ya c'est à monsieur très bien élevé très
cultivé qui un soir de détresse soir de
peine s'aventure chez une dame de petite
vertu
elle rentre dans l'appartement et il
voit une bibliothèque étonnante
il ya des livres sur la médecine exact
erreurs mais j'ai coupé mais
mademoiselle je suis un peu surpris tout
de même
est ce que vous vous y connaissez
quelque chose il oui je suis docteur en
médecine
je vous en fais mon puis je voyais une
journée les philosophes des cards quand
est ce que vous y connaissez quelque
chose oui je suis docteur philosophie
alors permettez-moi de m'étonner puis je
vais me permettre de vous poser une
question comment avec le bagad que vous
avez en êtes vous arrivé là et elle
répond j'ai eu de la chance